what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way and let's get started
so today also guys also if you want to
be the ultimate alpha male you want
women to come up to you left and right
you they'll just approach you you won't
even know what to do get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt today the
link is in the description we just
finished the design like this week in
the fabric so we should be shipping in
the next few weeks so make sure you guys
get yourself a shirt okay so we're going
to be covering a couple different topics
today um we're gonna go over Dylan
danis's um Logan Paul update then we're
gonna do
adam22 Clips going viral of him again
thank you
um and only fans workers causing
craziness once again in the school
system in relationships and all over so
okay let's start with Dylan Dennis so as
you guys know Dylan Dennis has been in
quite the Twitter feud with Logan Paul
and Nina Agdal so Logan and Dylan are
scheduled to fight him in the next month
right the fight is scheduled they're
ready to go and Dylan has basically been
calling Logan's fiancee a hoe for
everybody to see
literally everybody to see it's been bad
so bad yeah he just basically found
every picture of her with another guy
every guy she's dated and just has been
tweeting pictures left and right
um calling her a hoe
now Nina was done with this [__] Nina
says you know what Dylan even though
these pictures are all public
I'm still angry so she decides to file a
lawsuit and a restraining order against
Dylan danis so this is the picture of
them delivering him the cease and desist
letter and the restraining order you
know this guy's just been going hard and
Nina's done with it I don't really know
what you could possibly say when all
these images are already public
um I I think I think he tweeted some
nude pictures of her but uh were those
public do you guys I don't Dylan Dana's
tweets just landed and Pyongyang North
Korea to start his training camp
this man is so done he's so done
um and I it kind of begs the question is
the fight gonna get canceled is is he
gonna get arrested I I don't oh no
so Dylan says the only way I would
settle with Nina AG doll is if every
dollar she receives from me goes to the
victims of crypto Zoo
all right I'm thinking he's going after
Logan again because now maybe he's gonna
stop going after Nina it'll be injury
does this mean that the picture is real
oh my gosh guys you know Logan's saying
the picture's fake it's not real I bet
it's real
because I mean she's suing all right so
George Janko finally reacts to the Logan
vs Dylan fight and is giving his
thoughts
Dylan Dennis the Menace
it's a severe violence dude this this is
every man's fear this is this is the
reason why on every [__] first date
the guy goes so how many guys have you
been with you know I mean bro right
here's the thing don't dish out what you
can't take
if you bring he brought his girl
involved Savannah I remember that right
they brought his girl involved they were
talking about oh she was in the DMS and
all that [__] so like I get it but damn
that's some pepped up aggression bro he
kept that [__] in for a long time first
of all who the [__] is doing the
research for you Dennis who is this
there's at least
the CIA Dennis who's giving you this
[__] bro and then he says he has a nuke
that he hasn't even dropped brother if
what you have is the nuke what the [__]
was the other [__] yeah that's too much
bro my boy is straight openheim in real
life bro hey question yeah you said you
got in trouble what did you get in
trouble about before we started yeah
what do you mean trouble why are you
giving me that face you said you
commented on something and you got in
trouble oh yeah I won't say his name but
I I might have commented a couple
laughing faces on one of the pictures
that Dylan posted and someone very close
to Logan reached out and said hey you
should probably take the [__] down oh
can I know I'll be about the name um
[Music]
he sent me like 30 text messages
on a Sunday I was trying to [__]
enjoy my Sunday you just did laughing
emojis dude I just pull laughing emojis
because it's a funny thing that just
goes to show how gnarly the content is
that if you laugh at it it's like bro
that's [__] up yeah yeah people are
thinking this is Mike that said that
Logan's you know friend who's been
ducking me I've been he's been tweet
he's always tweeting at me he's all he
all of these tweets you know like trying
to say what I'm saying isn't true men
love the [__] which they do for sex
but you guys already know you know and
and I say Mike come on the show let's
talk about he's been ducking me forever
I'm waiting
um but we don't know that's a legend but
back to what they were talking about in
the in the video yeah that is every
guy's worst fear and unfortunately you
know and
in times past women could do crazy stuff
and the men could just forget they could
just you know
I don't really know what happened I
don't want to know but now there's
evidence that lives forever on the
internet the internet never forgets
ever
and you know Adam 22 decided to get
involved in this so Dylan's tweet in
about getting sued right and Adam 22
comes in and he says that's what you get
for [__] shaming
and Dylan comes back and he says I love
[__] this is just getting out of
control this is getting out of hand and
on one hand I do have a little bit of
empathy for Nina okay I do I do
um not really but but a little bit like
you know she didn't ask
to be dragged in the middle of this but
I mean I mean you marry I mean you're
getting on Camp you know what I mean
like sometimes as chicks it's like we
don't have to be on camera and then we
get on camera and kind of like whine
with all this stuff so you know but but
I do I do Nina come on the show let's
let's give your side there's two sides
to every story there's two so let's
let's let her talk yeah and Adam
Adam Adam not again
like stop trying to make marrying [__]
cool
it's not cool because it really it leads
to it's a generational problem and the
guy's putting up with this are really
you know at my issue and a lot of people
ask me this they'll be like Pearl well
guys are they all simps if they marry
not a virgin and I'm like well I didn't
say that but damn near you guys are
giving
um rings to women that do nothing like
absolutely nothing they don't offer any
wife skills they just nag all the time
and [__] and then they have sex on
camera it's like what are these guys
getting out of this once my kid gets to
the age where she understands or maybe
she could like get it in steps like oh
Mom Mom is a model mom's doing a photo
shoot today like people oh mom makes
money because people like the photos of
Mom Mom's getting BBC
no okay thank you snico thank you this
is this is what I'm talking about like
and you know I I never claim that you
know everybody has to live up to
everything perfectly right and we have
to be perfect but I don't know guys
we're getting pretty off the rails when
we're getting banged on camera and we're
saying well we'll tell the kids that mom
takes pictures someday you know it'll be
interesting because at some point kids
talk at some point these kids grow up
and they'll have their say they'll have
their opinion A lot of times they're not
gonna have very nice things to say about
you because you lived your whole life
pursuing money instead of values and
being selfish it's it this whole thing
is debauchery it's absolute selfishness
and you know and this is what we see a
generation of only fans models a
generation of [__] that are going to
be wives and mothers and um you know
even girlfriends like I don't even
understand why guys take only fans
models and like strippers as a girl I
don't get it we have another only fans
chick that showed up to class naked
now guys I'd like to say I mean I think
I think it's clear when we do this kind
of stuff that some of this stuff is
staged some people do it for views like
we know this we live in a crazy world
um but this is why I say what comes
first do men ask for sex or do women beg
for attention and take off their clothes
I'm gonna argue over and over again that
women will take off their clothes before
men will ask for sex because it's like
you know the men will have their male
only spaces right they used to be male
only
um universities work
um bars and the women will say Madison
let us in oh please oh please let us in
please please let us in they'll say Okay
women
you can come all right come into the
schools come into the bars and then
we'll just slowly start taking our
clothes off and if we take off our
clothes and they say hey you're not
following dress code then we cry a river
and call them sexist it's like we can't
win
um and then we act like men taking off
their shirts is the same as us taking
off our shirts men don't have boobs are
you guys stupid like I don't and then
these feminists these wild feminists
will just cry about their oppression
because they can't get naked think about
that guys think of think about how silly
of a world this is we cry on the
internet because we can't get naked
that's how bad we want to get naked like
what
this is bad God like this is not this is
not I'm not proud of this you know
um and this is why as women we really
gotta understand that a lot of our the
way we feel is through emotion we want
to do something we feel like we should
be able to do it when a lot of times
um men telling us no is them protecting
us and this is the thing men they'll
just kind of let us be idiots they
really will because they don't want the
drama they don't want the trouble
they'll just let us go and if guys come
and say something to you usually they've
thought about it for a while usually you
know especially like guys in Authority
or that care about you
um
but you know we just don't listen we
don't listen ever it's it's terrible
we can't y'all all came here to learn
correct yes yes
I don't care what she's wearing I just
want to do my presentations
so we can get on with this like just put
on some gym clothes or something this is
close yeah yeah I can give you my hood
is that would that help
okay
I want to get you guys to show you the
simp
did you see that simp in the back he's
like I don't care what she's wearing
[__]
you know she shouldn't be doing that
you know and now he's like well I I
don't care
really
and it's so silly it's like all these
guys I get so tired of it just tell us
what we want to hear because they either
don't want trouble or they want to get
laid he's like maybe I can get this
chick's number after
and when the truth of the matter is all
this [__] had to do was put some
clothes on that's it it's not that hard
um and honestly if if someone's saying
something to you about it is it really
that hard like just put on some pants or
go home learn from home stop torturing
out the rest of us with having to look
at your naked body I don't want to see
it I don't like I I you know what I was
thinking about I was thinking about
could it the men like okay if a guy
really wanted to be pure and he said I
want to wait till I'm married and I just
want to be a pure guy we don't have a
society that allows him to
because everywhere he goes these chicks
are half naked he goes to work they're
half naked he goes to the gym they're
half naked he goes outside they're half
naked it's like women we just keep
taking off our clothes I was thinking
like men should be able to like Sue
women for ruining their purity we can
take them to court if they assault us
right shouldn't I feel like the men
should be able to go to court for women
that just get naked in front of them for
no reason yeah I
I'm serious guys because it's like
I'm just I just get really tired of this
I get really exhausted really tired okay
now this is what I want to do I want to
talk about the women that sell dreams
because it builds a brand now as you
guys know Twitter I just go crazy on
Twitter that's my thing I love Twitter
um that's my Twitter pearly things go
follow it I'm trying to get to 400k you
know what's crazy guys I started off at
like 20K like six months ago almost a
325 look it I killed the Twitter game so
this is a chick named um Elita and um it
says Amala Clooney Met George Clooney at
35 the love of her life this was her
speech to him according to Red Pill
Twitter she should have married he
should have married an 18 year old
virgin whilst cheating on her every now
and then love will find it when you
least expect it if you're open to it can
we play the video I Met George when I
was 35 and starting to become quite
resigned to the idea that I was going to
be a spinster
then we met
started hiding out in my London flat and
very soon it felt like no matter what
happened I would never want to be with
anyone else
I couldn't sleep when we were apart and
I'm told that I would display a
particular grin and head tilt when
reading his text messages or the letters
that he would hide in my bag
five years later none of that has
changed
he is the person who has my complete
admiration and also the person who smile
makes me melt every time
my love
what I have found with you is the great
love that I always hoped existed and
seeing you with our children Ella and
Alexander is the greatest joy in my life
you fill our home with laughter and
happiness and that's even before the
children have worked out that Dada is
actually Batman a talking Fox and
Friends with Mary Poppins
I am so proud of you my love
congratulations on this great honor that
you're receiving tonight I am proud of
you but I also know that when our
children find out not only what you have
done but who you are they will be so
proud of you too
this is what I call shaming us for
living in reality okay and selling
dreams for money now I don't really know
who this chick is so nothing personal
please don't go on a Twitter rant about
how mean I am I'm criticizing the idea
not you now all right
so she's I'm gonna break down what she's
saying Amala Met George Clooney at 35
the love of her life and this was her
speech to him according to Red Pill
Twitter he should have married an 18
year old virgin while cheating on her
every now and that
no that's not what I say that's as as a
chick in the red pill that's not what I
say I say and this is the thing what
they'll do is the women they can't
process things with logic so they'll be
like ah I'm so emotional and then
they'll just be like well they said he
should only marry an 18 year old virgin
no no I said virgins are better and
younger women are better there's
exceptions right and this is what I said
women will sell dreams that really only
happen for exceptionally beautiful
models because it sounds nice now again
this sounds amazing it's not reality and
we're constantly being pandered to
um yeah and like I'm really happy you
know it seems like they have a good
marriage so I would never say that he
should have went with an 18 year old
model he seems to find what works for
him
um but the point is that Amal got this
because she's really really hot hot
women get you know special privileges
and the truth of the matter is most
women that follow her and that listen to
me are average I'm an average chick most
women are average and the truth of the
matter is at 35 your odds of getting
married as a chick is like 15 you know
if you get to 30 it's like your odds of
getting married is like 20 if you're a
single mother your odds of getting
married is like 10 13. I'm this is rough
estimates right but
so I could say women it'll be you when
the truth of the matter is
in My Generation
Um it's really not gonna be us and
really
um the the Next Generation should just
learn from our generation that this is
going downhill
um let's take mine they're predicting
half of us will be single and childless
so that's 50 right then let's take the
other half that do get married half of
those will get divorced
that's three out of four we'll have not
fairy tale endings three out of four of
us will die alone that means you're more
likely to be the rule than the exception
and selling this dream that it's gonna
work out for you
instead of saying look it let's take
this l
and and at least be honest to the Next
Generation and say hey get married young
don't become an old spinster like this
chick you're probably not gonna get
George Clooney that certainly is not
happening for you chica like imagine
imagine okay imagine okay her
right her evidence
well George Clooney married a model
it's like okay
and then that doesn't even that doesn't
even take into account
who was gonna be in the room with George
cloon like
and so then they'll they'll this is what
they'll do I'll live in reality and I'll
say look
um guys I'm just being honest it's not
gonna it's not gonna end well for most
of us
um really again we should just be honest
with the Next Generation and if I was a
guy I would just pass up these old
chicks I'd pass up and I'd go get a 21
year old and take away your phone
because this is going great like that's
what I would do
and and she'd probably be happier too
you know social media makes us depressed
you know it's like that's enough if I
was a guy that's what I would do or I
would just not deal with women at all
and that's what a lot of guys are
picking and and this is what they'll do
they'll say well you're a doomsdayer
pearl you're just the big meanie and I
and I look and honestly guys
we're in a post-marriage society
uh the Trad cons really haven't caught
up yet but marriage isn't marriage
anymore it doesn't exist it's gone
um under 40 how many couples do you know
that have been married 10 years and
that's really where I see the
generational shift is like okay the 40
to 60 year olds roughly was the last
generation of shitty wives yup yeah yeah
so actually I'm gonna break this down a
little further so what I found is the 60
to 80 year old women
they had a shitty mindset but they were
okay wives so they cooked you know they
cleaned they they did they they knew
they were supposed to be like like with
their husband they didn't get divorced
many separated but didn't divorce
um there were some divorces that was
like the beginning of the end right but
they had really bad mindsets they felt
like we should have 50 50 like 50 it's
equal they didn't really believe in
obeying their husband if you look at
that like there's little telltale signs
that you can tell like if you look at
the house is it his house or her house
typically it would be her house which
she wanted and the family dynamic in the
home a lot of times was what she wanted
and you know they would kick kick out
their husbands over stupid reasons like
money or whatever like it's like even
though he brought home all the money she
felt like she needed to be in control of
it like stuff like this because this is
when the propaganda really like hit that
generation heavy
so generation one shitty mindset and
they told their daughters to always have
a backup plan they told their daughters
to go to work they often trash talked
their husbands to their daughters so now
and women again it's the same propaganda
method oh here's a scary story fear fear
fear so then all those women they run to
work and that's the first generation the
40 to like roughly 60 year olds
generation of truly shitty wives that's
like the generation before could still
cook they could still clean they could
you know they still had like skills but
the next generation was just like God
awful like they just they they really
couldn't like cook or clean I mean they
maybe knew a little bit from childhood
but they didn't really teach their
daughters anything or their son well the
men are good people so they'll still
teach their sons stuff more so than the
women but yeah and so then the 40 to 60
year olds that's like the real
generation of Devore like that they ruin
marriage to be honest and I would argue
maybe up to 65s the the women that I
I've interviewed and stuff that have a
more like real like good mindset where
they obey their men seems to be like the
80 to 100 year olds
guys how crazy is that so we've had one
on one not two but three generations of
shitty wives and what does this mean
what does this mean for us this means
that a lot of times skills get lost in
three generations and I really think
that the skills of being a wife has been
lost in three generations so much so
that do you know what's really funny
what's really interesting how much women
like Miss the point
because what they'll do is they'll focus
on like like you'll see these women
selling femininity right and a lot of
these femininity courses and a lot of it
is based on looks it's based on these
like rules for the men like these 90-day
rules
at its core femininity it's not about
the way you look it's it's not about
um etiquette
it's not about your career what what
femininity is about is serving others
it's obeying that is true femininity do
you think our ancestors were farmers
okay do you think the women on the farm
were that worried about their Botox
Nails the fake hair
no that's like putting a Band-Aid over
the real problem and the real problem is
the generation before us was a
generation of shitty selfish wives and
they taught us to go to college and
focus on our career they taught us that
we were more important they taught us
happy wife happy life they taught us
that it's all about balance that you
should have a say when the truth of the
matter is that men built this world men
run this world and men should run their
households and it's all propaganda and
it's wrong and these femininity coaches
come in and they just try to control the
men in a different way when the truth of
the matter is true femininity
is exerting zero control over the men in
your lives that's that's what made
marriages work and the funny thing is um
the Trad concerts will revert to
while women used to be at home
not really women were out in the fields
working
and this idea that women didn't work is
the dumbest [__] I've ever heard of
women have always worked they had
exceptionally hard lives I think we
would die the women today I would die if
I had to live life like a chick a
hundred years ago they'd get up they
would milk the cows they would be in the
garden they would tow the fields like
they were helping their family but the
point was they would all come together
and it was for the family not themselves
that's true femininity and when you
think of this and let's bring this into
real life the women that you know maybe
it's a grandmother maybe it's a great
grandmother those women that are truly
like feminine right when you think of
like the most high quality women you
know
are they focused on makeup and hair and
all of that stuff or were they so
selfless that everybody around them
loved them were they so selfless that
they have these recipes that they come
in and you just feel like you're at home
that's that's what true femininity is
but the problem is we have all these
women trying to make money and profit
that get a ring but are just disguise
and I call them the disguised wives they
look like a wife they seem like a wife
they have the ring like a wife but they
don't act like a wife and I saw this
when I tweeted
um on conservative Twitter I said happy
wife happy life with a barfing emoji and
the entire tradcon said well it's about
balance well what about what she wants
like you should get wisdom from your
wives no guys that's feminism the
natural order of the world it's supposed
to go God men women children you are not
supposed to exert control over your
husband it's his program that and and
guys
this is the only way I see it work and
and you know when the women when it
becomes one of these balanced these
quote unquote balanced relationships
this is what I see
um it's really just what the woman wants
it's never a balance because men are
generally content they're not really
going to complain they just kind of take
it and women will always complain and
will always whine that's just what we do
and man of previous generations knew
that and they would keep us in check but
the problem is we give them no Authority
and we say that women are the Smart Ones
really these [__] on only fans are
the Smart Ones
come on like and this is silly and it
and you really can see the mindset of
what and this is the thing guys truly
feminine wives actually don't get mad
about this stuff and I'll tell you why
because I I know women
um that really were Housewives and
really believed they obeyed their
husband they wanted when he came home
they didn't want him to lift a finger
okay now you know that's not the
reputation of wives today and those
women hadn't had have had an extremely
hard time because their friends would
shame them their friends just don't get
it so when I say that's the generation
of shitty wives they don't get mad they
say I know because I've been alone they
are lonely they don't have this gut
reaction and say oh well that's not all
women no they know it doesn't apply to
them and they they it's it's like it's a
very lonely life for women that truly
want to be traditional you know what
their friends will say that you're
you're being controlled even Christian
wives will say oh she's just his she
just does whatever he says and
that's they don't realize that's the way
it's supposed to be your husband isn't
supposed to ask your permission your
husband can do whatever he wants with
the money true submission is giving him
complete control and not trying to
control him I'm not saying chicks got to
do this for every single guy but what
what I am saying is uh if you do not do
that we're not perfect right so no no
chick's gonna do that perfectly but if
we can't even agree that that is the aim
that is the goal then the next
generation is going to be even shittier
wise but the problem is we have all
these wives that we're supposed to learn
from that don't even have the mindset of
the wife it's not even about working
right like my great grandma she she
married
um she married a baker right and she was
a nurse that's a quote unquote higher
status job and do you know what she did
she still gave him three meals a day and
she worked it's not about working guys
it's not even about working inside or
outside of the home it's about
everything is the family first
everything is your husband first it's
not about you and that's that's our
problem is social media has has made us
women live in this complete delusion and
narcissism where we think our career is
the most important thing and this is why
I say real traditional women
um get married before 25 the real the
real the real deals and I'll explain why
because they think it's important to
give their husband their most fertile
and Youthful years they know that's
important to men they want to give their
husband the best of them that's why they
wait until they're married to have sex
that's why and that those are the women
that were raised to truly be traditional
they're rare they barely they they
they're almost damn near extinct but the
only way that we could ever come back
from that is if we agree on what the
goal is and the problem is women we
can't even agree we will [__] and whine
whenever I say hey that's that's the
best type of wives and then you have
women like this that come in and sell
you dreams that don't exist the truth of
the matter is Our Generation
Um
25 to 35 year old women most of us
aren't going to have a happy ending
um but really what we should do is talk
to the younger women and be honest with
them and tell them what the goal is
because the other issue too with women
that marry young is that they feel like
they're missing out
because our generation tells them they
are can you imagine that women get
married and have children and and our
generation of women
says to them that you're missing out you
need to hold off do all these things
first
and women are so easily misled and the
problem is now we've given women
Authority the ultimate Authority and for
whatever reason when women have a lot of
choice we just choose
destruction you know out of the kindness
of my heart I'm gonna you know start
giving giving you guys some advice so I
have a story from Reddit
here you know and and I love I love
giving the people advice so and I I
never know if they're real or not but
let's just I mean this has probably
happened to somebody right okay
I found out my girlfriend was a
prostitute
oh my gosh
I 32 recently found out that my 29 year
old female girlfriend has been working
for sex on and off the last nine years
my girlfriend and I have been dating for
three months and everything is great we
have great chemistry and have a lot in
common I believe she's the one I want to
marry until last weekend we went out
with the friends for drinks last
Saturday and got drunk my girlfriend
fell asleep while her friends and I
continued talking and drinking her best
friend accidentally had a tongue slip
and told me that my girlfriend had a lot
more sexual experience than me she said
my girlfriend was a stripper when she
was 20 and had sex often with clients
she did this on and off for nine years
her friend knows this because she also
worked with her I'm horrified and
disgusted
I don't know what to do
okay this is why I say women can't trust
women you see that chick knew what she
was doing
um you got a dump her okay this
I don't care what she says any chick
that that was doing sex work is far too
damaged to deal with uh she's gone she's
done get yourself a 21 year old keep
building yourself because
this
and and this is the sad thing women are
more it's it's funny because women are
Gonna Keep like trying to hide
everything and the men are gonna keep on
coming up with devices to figure [__]
out like internet search background when
there's a will there's a way the mental
the metal figures [__] out
um
yeah I think and and this is the problem
guys the problem is that
we have the like these are this is the
next generation of wives it's going
downhill this is why I tell men to date
younger this is why I say the best women
are married before 25 because what were
you doing before it's either a career
right it's either the club I don't know
what it is it's different for each chick
right
but at least you get them younger they
could spend their best years focusing on
the Family
and that's the most important thing and
that's the real problem guys is that
um
it like women women hide this stuff they
hide it really well and you know people
act like the women were just coerced
into sex work or like they felt like
they had no other choice oh no they knew
women know that McDonald's is always an
option the truth of the matter is
they're just lazy and they want
attention some women don't even do it
for the money they just want attention I
mean think about how many broke only
fans models there they're selling their
their stuff for like 5.99 and no one's
buying
this is why I just say a female promised
you would be left unchecked kills and
ruined Society we're all taught the
wrong things we're all confused and
we're all just trying to figure it out
and the thing that's why I love what I
do because you know even even me like
every chick has been confused every guy
has been confused and at least we can
all come together and figure it out
don't shoot the messenger get yourself a
women shouldn't vote shirt today none of
this craziness would be going on would
be happening if women didn't vote so
make sure you get that the link is in
the description like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel and
I'll talk to you next time